flanked by his legal team ryan giggs
appeared in court to plead not guilty
on all three counts in the indictment
against him
the former manchester united footballer
allegedly threw his
ex-girlfriend naked out of their hotel
room
as part of what is described as
controlling and coercive behavior
against 36 year old kate greville
between august 2017
and november 2020 he's also accused of
actual bodily harm against her
and common assault against her sister at
his home in manchester
last november the details accuse him of
threatening to send
emails to her friends and employers
about the pair's sexual relationship and
behavior
throwing her belongings out of his house
when she questioned him
about relationships with other women and
kicking her in the back
before throwing her out of the hotel
bedroom naked
shortly after he was initially charged
ryan giggs issued a statement in which
he denied
all of the allegations and said he
looked forward to clearing his name
in the meantime he's on leave from his
job as the boss of the welsh football
team
he's already missed the euro 2020
tournament and is set to miss
a series of world cup qualifiers this
autumn
the trial at manchester crown court is
set to start on january 24th next year
sadia chowdhury sky news in manchester